because you're asking for a sign for
something about someone. You're in love
with somebody and you want to know if
that's the person because this person in
your life is causing you to stumble and
you know you're in sin and therefore God
make it clear, should I be with her or
should I let her go? And instead Jesus
showed up, right?
>> Uh Jesus, yes, Jesus showed up. Yes. So
instead of that person that you're
struggling with because you don't know
if that person is for you, but you have
an attachment and you want to know God's
will for you and that person, right?
>> Um I was supposed to see the person's
siblings, but I saw Jesus instead.
>> And so you wanted to see if this is the
person that God has for you, right?
>> Um
yes. If there's a better way to go about
the situation. Yes. Yes.
>> Yes. So, what I'm trying to get at is
there's a situation involving someone of
the opposite sex,
>> right?
>> Yes.
>> You understand how I just gave away what
you were hiding from me? Were you
listening?
>> True.
>> Yes. So, here's a person of the opposite
sex, and you want to know
whether it is God's will for you to go
ahead with her or not?
>> No. The thing is it's
>> what is it?
>> So basically we're we're trying to do
the right thing, right? Because the
right
>> what I just said
>> would be the right thing.
>> Yeah. To get married and get engaged or
get
>> You're in sin with her, right?
>> We're we're not doing anything, right?
We're not
we're together, but we're not like
it's not in marriage, right? Which is
not okay.
>> So which is instead
Just
>> you're right. It's a sin. It's a sin.
Definitely.
>> That means I nailed it, right?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. So, why you hiding it from me when
it just came to me? That means now the
spirit is speaking.
>> You're right.
>> Okay. So, now the spirit just used me to
expose what you are hiding.
>> And you never told me this before,
right?
>> No.
>> Okay. So,
you just confirm what I just said that
you are in a relationship with a person
that you're sinning with.
Yes.
>> And therefore, you're fornicating.
>> We're not. We're not.
>> You just said, "We're not married. We're
together." So, what are you doing?
Playing patty cake. Patty cake. Patty
cake.
>> No, we we um we don't we haven't slept
together, so we're not doing that.
>> Okay. You have never done it. So, you
Good. Good. But
>> yeah, we have never
>> Then the dilemma you have, Here's what
I'm trying to figure out. If you're not
fornicating with her,
>> Good. You're not having sex. Good. May
God give us the grace that we all stay
pure.
Why are you having a problem with being
with her unless now she's one
>> parents?
>> Okay, but that's what I'm trying to get.
Why would the parents have a problem
with you unless she's not of the same
faith
or
there's something about your lifestyle
that shows to them that you're not
really mature enough, responsible
enough, and a devoted Christian? Which
is it?
>> Parents don't want
the daughter to
um
>> so you even hesitate
>> get married. Parents don't want the
daughter to get married and she have the
same faith.
>> No.
>> Bingo. You're in sin.
Bingo.
Why the hell are you in love with
someone who's not of the same faith?
I just didn't think it was it was a
problem.
>> Oh, you mean so in 2 Corinthians 6:14:18
and 1 Corinthians 7:39 and 1 Corinthians
15:33 where it says do not be unequally
yolked with unbelievers and if you are
to marry you marry only in the Lord and
bad company corrupts good morals. So the
Bible says don't do it but to you it's
no problem. Huh?
>> You're right.
>> What are you doing with someone of a
different religion?
I just believe that hey God
>> doesn't matter what you believe. You are
the slave of Jesus. You are the property
of Jesus. Jesus is your Lord. He's not
your servant. If he's your Lord, he
tells you how to live your life. So I
don't care what you believe. I'm telling
you what Jesus, my Lord, who owns me and
owns you, says. So why are you
disobedient to your Lord?
>> You're right.
>> Okay. How old are you, young man?
Right now I'm 28.
>> Okay. How old is she?
>> She's 18.
>> Wow. She's 10 years younger than you.
>> Yeah.
>> Which again I'm She's mature enough. But
my my question to you is of what
religion is she?
>> Prophet Muhammad.
>> I know it. I just wanted you to confess
it.
What in the world are you doing in love
with a Muslim girl who's 18? And
secondly, the reason why Jesus appeared
to you, you know what he's telling you
when he appeared, not her?
>> Yeah.
>> You know what he was telling you, right?
>> No.
>> It's clear as day. You wanted God to
show you she's the one and to give you
the green light. He says, "No, I own
you. I am your Lord. If you're part of
my church, you're my bride and the bride
has to obey my voice.
But you're not obeying him because
you're putting her ahead of Jesus.
Now, I understood why Jesus appeared,
not this girl. Because let's be honest,
you were hoping your will would be God's
will, that she's the one, right?
>> Yes.
>> And then Jesus says, "No, she's not.
So now I see why you're too afraid and
ashamed to say it. But see, the Lord
revealed it. I didn't know what it was.
And I'm not, guys, I'm being honest.
This is the first time I'm hearing from
this guy. He's never told me anything.
But as I was talking to him, it came to
me. It has to do with a woman of another
religion. Either it's fornication, he's
having sex with her, that's why he's
troubled, or it's she's another
religion, or it's both. And I still
suspect contrary to what you tell me
now, brother, don't be af lying to me.
You have been intimate with her. I think
you're lying to me.
>> No, we have not.
>> Not at all.
>> No.
>> Okay. Now, remember, only God knows. I'm
not a prophet.
>> No, that's the truth. Yeah, that's
>> okay. Good. Then then your conscience is
clear because if you are fornicating
with her, now you're adding two sins.
Someone of the Islamic faith
and on top of that fornicate. Now, thank
the Lord you haven't fornicated, but
you're still in sin cuz you're not
supposed to be in love with her. So, let
me guess. You think you're in love with
her, right?
>> I would say so. Yes, definitely.
>> And she thinks she's in love with you,
right?
>> Yes.
>> How long you've been together seeing
each other?
>> Going up to 10 months.
>> It's time for you to say bye to her.
Jesus says in Matthew 10:34-39,
Matthew 10:34-39
and Matthew
24-28
as well as Luke 6:46:49.
He who loves me must carry his cross,
deny himself, die to self, and he must
love me more than father and mother,
more than spouse and children, and must
be willing to lose the world to gain me.
And he says, "Why do you call me Lord,
Lord, and not do the things I say?" Open
up Luke 6, and I want you to read it.
Luke 6:46-49.
>> So, you got your answer that you were
trying to hide, but the Lord exposed it,
didn't he?
>> Yes.
And you see how my demeanor changed and
became dead serious once it became clear
to me what you were hiding.
>> True. It says uh
>> 46 to 49.
>> Why do you call me Lord, Lord,
and do not do what I say? As for
everyone who comes to me and hears my
words and puts them into practice, I
will show you what they are like.
They are like a men building a house who
dug down deep and laid the foundation on
a rock. When a when a flood came, a
torrent struck that house but could not
shake it because it was wellb built. But
the one who hears my words and does not
put them into practice is like a man who
build a house on the ground
>> without. One who hears my words, Mel,
and does not put them in practice. So,
you just heard the words of Jesus. And
who does not put them into practice is
like what?
>> He's like uh
uh
>> is like a man who built a house on the
ground without a foundation.
>> So, what happens to him? Luke 6:46 to
49. If you keep reading 49,
>> uh, the moment deterren struck that
house, it collapsed and it its
destruction was complete.
>> Oh,
so Jesus just said, you heard my words.
You don't put in practice, your
destruction will be complete. So God has
answered you. You want to God answer
you, you need to leave her be. Move on.
Stop
causing her to fall deeper in love
because she's too young to know what
true love is. She thinks she's in love
because she's too young and you've taken
advantage of her because she's young.
>> In fact, I'm gonna ask you another
question. And not to judge you, but
you're gonna have to be honest.
>> Yeah.
>> Prior to this discussion of mine with
me, have you fornicated? Have you had
sex before marriage?
>> Yes.
>> Yes. Exactly. This what makes you self
selfish and evil in the sight of God?
I'm going to tell you why. Listen to me.
She's a virgin, isn't she?
>> Yes. See why? Why? You're wicked and
evil. You've slept around with women and
defiled them in yourself, but now you
want to keep her because she's a virgin
and you want a virgin.
Shame on you.
You're wicked and selfish. You know
that, right?
>> Um,
>> this is why
>> I would I wouldn't say
>> No, I would say it. No, I'm gonna say I
don't care what you say. I'm telling
you, you found her when she was 17
because she was a virgin and pretty.
>> No, when I found her, she was 18. Yes.
>> Oh, you said 10 months ago. When did she
turn 18?
>> Uh, it's about to be 10 months. In
April.
>> Okay. So, when was she 17?
>> Because you said 10 months. So, she was
still 18 10 months ago.
>> No, when I met her, she was 18. Yeah.
>> Oh, so she was 18. She wasn't 17. Who
turned 18? Yeah, she about to be 19 now.
She about to be 19.
>> Oh, so okay. So, okay, you found 18.
Even Okay, now she's gonna be 19.
>> Yeah, she better be 19.
>> Okay. Even 18. I just thought 10 months.
Okay. Okay. So, 18, you found her
because she's a virgin. Obviously,
>> she's also attractive. But you're 28.
That's the first red flag that went in
my mind.
>> I just turned 28. So,
>> so you're only 9 years older. That makes
it easier. You're not listening, buddy.
Listen to me. The first red flag that
went in my mind was he's 28. She's 18.
Usually someone in 28 is going to look
for someone in the 20s. But again, be
that as it may. Put that aside. Now, I
see why you want to be with her because
she's a virgin. And you want to be with
her because every man wants a virgin.
Every woman wants a virgin. But sucks
being you, buddy. You're not going to
have her because she's not of the Lord.
She doesn't belong to Christ. You have
no business being with a Christian. And
on top of that, you've already sinned
against God by fornicating. And you
think now you deserve a virgin,
you need to repent, man.
You need to repent. You now heard the
will of God, the word of God. You don't
listen. Watch the discipline and the
wrath the Lord's going to unleash on you
to teach you the fear of the Lord. Let
her go. Leave her be. Let her go. Leave
her be. Now, you know God's will. That's
all I can tell you. You don't do it.
You've heard God's word and we're all
witnesses.
Watch what the Lord's going to do to you
and disciplining you if you don't do
what God now warns you to do. That's
between you and God, man. I'm not going
to live your life. Let her go. Leave her
be. You don't deserve that virgin. And
she's not supposed to be with you cuz
she's not even a Christian. Don't be
that selfish. All right.
>> True.
>> Sorry, buddy. Get back to me when you
repent. Next time I hear from you, Sam,
I've let her go. I've gone to the
priest. I've made confession. I'm now
walking the walk. I'm keeping myself
pure. I'm not having sex until marriage.
And I'm trusting Jesus. You know, this
is the spirit, right, that brought it up
because you're trying to hide and the
spirit did not let you hide.
>> True.
>> All right.
>> Well, thank him because that means he
loves you and he's warning you.
>> All right.
>> Uh, thank you.
>> There you go, guys. The spirit
eventually brought it out. Isn't that
amazing? May the Spirit perfect us and
correct our mistakes. It dawned on me
and I give glory to the Holy Spirit for
that.